[موسيقى]
تعود سوريا الى الحضن العربي لكنها لن
تعود لنفسها بسهوله فهي بحاجه لاكبر
فاتوره اعمار في التاريخ الحديث قدرتها
الجامعه العربيه ب 900 مليار دولار بينما
توقعت بعض المنظمات الامميه ان تصل
التكلفه الى 450 مليارا رقم كبير يحتاجه
السوريون لازاله الاثار المباشره باثني
عشر عاما من الحرب
امتدت تبع عيرتها السلبيه من ارهاب ودمار
ونزوح ولجوء الى سائر دول المنطقه والعالم
سكان سوريا بحاجه لمساعدات عاجله اثنى عشر
مليون مواطن اجبروا على الفرار من بيوتهم
نصفهم نزح داخل البلاد والنصف الاخر اصبح
حبيس مخيمات اللجوء في الدول المجاوره او
رفضته امواج البحر الى دول العالم
وقد تنجح ورشه اعمار دوليه مع استثمار
فعال لموارد سوريا في اعاده بناء البلاد
خلال سنوات طويله قادمه لكن الخسائر
البشريه والهدم الذي جرى في النفوس يستحيل
بناؤه
احبائه واقرباء واهل فقدوا في مسلسل قتل
طال نحو ثلاثمائه وخمسين الف شخص بينهم
300 الف مدني على الاقل
لمتابعه المزيد
من الاروع البرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات